do I look like a guy who has a
plan I mean I just do
[Music]
things hey
folks let's talk about villains or more
specifically let's talk about villain's
plans or more specifically than that
let's talk about why it doesn't matter
if they would work or
not I'll get more specific as we go but
I suppose I'll start with what am I even
talking about
well I I have my general issues with the
sort of H plot Hole uh this isn't real
that wouldn't go that way style of
criticism um I like I don't mind it when
people like enjoy it as an exercise or
like something things are so broken in
terms of plot that it does take you out
of movie that's a legit complaint but
like anytime it's masquerading his
criticism like oh the movie's bad
because this this thing is a plot hole
my crying out loud look a a plot hole
can make a bad movie worse a a plot hole
does not suddenly make a good movie Bad
it already needed a bunch of other stuff
going wrong with it but sort of in the
realm of that same Spirit of uh
criticism
you will find people sometimes
complaining that villains plans won't
work so like this is just
foolish why are we even bothering stop
this person like their PL not going to
work anyway why are they doing that have
they not thought it
through and I'd say about 95% of the
time I find this perspective uh
invalid and I don't like to say that
about like like you can have an opinion
that you don't like a villain's plan or
you don't think it's a good plot point
but to say that it matters that a
villain's plan ultimately in terms of
achieving their final goal wouldn't
work doesn't matter I'll explain why not
and I'll even use some specific examples
in order to do so here's the short
version
though it doesn't matter if a villain's
plan isn't going to work all that
matters is that they think it will
work and they will cause massive damage
in trying to achieve it whether or not
they could actually achieve what they're
trying to achieve whether or not is
logistically possible whether or not it
would actually play out the way they
want whether they have miscalculated
none of that matters all that really
matters for a villain to function for
the purposes of a
story do they think that what they're
going to do is going to work work and is
it harmful for them to try forget
succeed is it harmful for them to even
try and if both of those are
true then whether or not the final plan
works or could work or has a million
holes in it doesn't matter I'll give you
a couple of examples partly
because the fact that these villains
plans wouldn't work doesn't even need to
be a bug it can be a feature a feature
of the charact
it tells you something about these
people that they think these plans will
work so this is where I'm going to cite
some specific examples because otherwise
I could probably end the video there
let's start with the one I I remember
seeing it most
about uh you know a few years ago and he
still comes up
Thanos the idea that Thanos has planed
to wipe out half of life in the universe
as as a way to curb the growth of life
and um keep resources managed and
whatnot more than a few people have
pointed out that wouldn't work I mean
aside from the fact that it is so far as
we can tell completely random who dies
like you could have accidentally just by
sheer numbers killed the people who were
cultivating the food and the people who
are left don't know how to do that and
so the whole place is going to get wiped
out but even if everything balances
perfectly and also like it's of life not
just sensient life so like you're also
in theory wiping out the the um animals
used in agriculture and for meat and for
feeding like if you're cutting those in
half too then didn't you just have the
exact same ratio problem you just have a
smaller raw number but even if we set
all of that aside at best this is
rolling the clock back people are going
to breed we're really good at it so
aren't we just going to run into the
same problem in however long all of this
stuff is valid criticism of whether or
not his plan would actually work now
it's kind of an interesting side note
that this was never his intention as to
why he wiped out half of life in the
universe in the comics and the comics he
did it to impress death because Thanos
is a real big incel in the comics and he
is trying to impress a girl who does not
care about him but the movies didn't go
with that but the fact that his plan is
self-defeating
and wouldn't
work doesn't matter because he believes
that the best way to curb anything you
know lack of resources whatever is to
Cull people he is the kind of person who
believes death is a solution to things
so the fact that he believes that this
is the ultimate correction says a lot
about him a lot about the way he thinks
a lot about his arrogance to assume that
that once he hit on an otion that'll
just work I'll just do that has he ever
stopped and actually fully thought about
it no possibly not that's actually in
some ways a little bit of the premise of
some of one of the wh if episodes the
one uh focusing on black panther people
like mocked this idea that black panther
like talked Thanos out of his mission
but the thing is like he could given
that his mission was supposed to help
and it wouldn't have worked so
that uh episode of what if which isn't
even a show I like that kind of implies
that nobody ever really got through to
him with the notion that yeah this isn't
going to work anyway but until tala did
in that one particular what if scenario
but regardless it still says a lot about
him whether or not specific Solutions
work when somebody looks at a lack of
resources if they think boy we should be
sure that the resources are that we have
are distributed as fairly as possible
and aren't pulled by an incredibly uh
unreasonably small number of people
versus somebody who thinks we should
just get rid of a whole bunch of these
people doesn't matter which would work
or if either would work what their
solution is says a lot about them as
people and thanos's solution says aot
lot about him in the MCU version of him
I mean what he does in the comics says a
lot about him too because again big
inel so that's one example here's
another one Doctor Who the last episode
of the jod Whitaker era featured the
master this particular Incarnation
played by Sasha
danan towards the latter half Sasha
danan basically kind of takes over the
doctor's life and body technically but
also turns into himself physically if
you don't know Doctor Who that much
they're both time Lords time Lords can
change their faces anyway but he
basically starts to go about and claim
to be the doctor you know doing horrible
things and saying I'm the doctor and I
did this
destroying whatever reputation she might
have had or at least attempting to and
I've had some people point out like this
is a very silly plan like why would
people believe him even if he does this
he's just going to turn the doctor's
name to just as much mud as his own name
as the master was so what's he
accomplishing out of this and if he
succeeded she she's effectively dead
anyway if he actually did succeed so
what's the point of this extra step what
what is this meant to
accomplish and it says a lot about him
that this is where his priorities are
I've talked about this in some other um
times when I've talked about about his
particular incarnation of the master but
he is deeply self-loathing that is that
was really evident to me by the time I
finish my rewatch of that era of Doctor
Who he really really cannot stand
himself
to so even though he is physically in
the shape of who he's always been the
fact that he left his own body and re
and took over the doctors even though he
reshaped it to look like himself he has
deluded himself into thinking that's the
same as a fresh start as getting to be
somebody else but he's both
self-loathing and can't change at least
this incarnation of him
can't so this says a lot about him
regardless of whether he could ever
accomplish what he was trying to do or
if he even really thought all the way
through about what his end goal was cuz
I think you could argue that he didn't
really have one he had various steps
that he intended to take and he took
them as he went along
did he have an end goal
even I'm not sure he did but even if he
did might not have
worked but it doesn't matter cuz he's
still dangerous because he was willing
to destroy the doctor and Earth and
whatever else he felt like in order to
do it I kind of skipped over that bit of
Thanos but obviously even if
thanos's um idea of culling half the
universe isn't going to work he's still
gonna wipe out half the universe and he
thinks it's gonna work
so those were the two things as I said
one more this one from Comics Super Boy
Prime specifically as shown in the
crossover event Infinite Crisis Super
Boy Prime is turned from Super Boy Prime
is a weird character to try to explain
so originally he was like from our world
like the Multiverse version of real
actual place where we all live it's
weird forget the history after crisis on
infinite Earth that collapsed the
Multiverse that was in the 80s he was
sent um to exist in effectively a locked
off little pocket Dimension with Earth 2
Superman and Lois Lane and he becomes a
monster because he and Superman have
been
watching the main Universe well at that
point the only Universe quote unquote um
when there wasn't a Multiverse of DC and
saw how dark and horrible and violent
and awful the heroes were
becoming and he thought you know what I
need to remake my world my world was
better now he's wrong he's feeling both
loss of what he doesn't have and also
the sense that the people who do still
have a universe do still have their
friends do still have their world
they've squandered it they don't
appreciate it so he's bitter and he's
grieving but he's also wrong
he's looking through Rose tinted glasses
at something that he doesn't have
anymore that he's allowed to think of as
being
perfect but it's not Superman from Earth
2 has the similar issue but because he's
Superman he gets talked down he gets
talked down because as gets pointed out
a truly perfect world wouldn't even need
a Superman super boy Prime on the other
hand he goes all out he goes vicious he
tries to destroy the universe into
peace obviously it's not going to work
but it doesn't matter that it's not
going to work because he is prepared to
tear the universe apart in his anger and
his rage to try and do
it similarly before the rcon for Hal
Jordan in the comics his initial turn to
evil was spurred by loss and grief and
an inability to
cope and he tried to bring his loved
ones back and he
couldn't but he did a hell of a lot of
damage
trying I mean heck very famous movie I
can step out of comics into a back into
a movie that most people would know um
we have an example of why this doesn't
matter the Joker from The Dark Night his
ultimate plan I mean whether it was his
ultimate plan or his only plan or how
many of these are overlapping plans it's
hard to tell with this guy uh as much as
he claims that he doesn't have a plan do
I really look like a guy with a plan as
much as he might claim that he was
ultimately building towards the two
ships
scenario expecting one ship to blow up
the other and they don't he failed he
was wrong he thought that when the chips
are
down these uh these civilized people
they'll eat each other but they didn't
cuz he was
wrong but wow did he kill a lot of
people and do a lot of damage getting
there to the point where it turned out
he was just wrong still needed to be
stopped still a very very dangerous
villain the fact that his plan
ultimately didn't work doesn't
matter that's not to say that a
villain's plan not working doesn't
matter across the board
in my mind a villain's end goal being
something that wouldn't work that
doesn't
matter however if the various component
parts of their
plan don't make sense or wouldn't work
or shouldn't work or should fall apart
for so many reasons but by some diabolis
exmachina they just
don't that is a problem and you can look
to Batman v Superman for that I'm sorry
I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry I'm not trying
to summon the SN of bros into my
comments but Lex Luthor's
plan is
absurd it has so many layers of
complexity so many layers of
needless
complication I'm not sure I could even
fully recount the whole thing but let me
see what I can come up with so his
plan is to go Batman into killing
Superman by framing Superman for killing
a bunch of terrorists in Africa which he
does by shooting them and claiming it
was Superman despite the fact that
Superman doesn't use a gun and he has
them shot with special bullets that only
he manufactures and can be traced back
to him so Congress will hold a hearing
as to whether or not Superman is
something that should be allowed
simultaneously intercepting checks
intended for somebody who was harmed in
the collapse of of the buildings from U
Man of Steel intercepting those checks
allowing that guy to go destitute who
happens to be somebody who worked for
Wayne Enterprises push him to the Limit
give him a wheelchair load that
wheelchair up with explosives wheel that
into Congress during the hearings blow
all of it up except for Superman so that
people will blame Superman for some
reason all of this in an effort to get
Batman to try and kill Superman
including getting Batman to steal the
Kryptonite and also he was working with
politicians to get the Kryptonite in
legitimately when he's breaking a
million laws for other things so he's
not just going to smuggle it in for some
freaking reason and then he's going to
kidnap Superman's mom and insists that
he go fight Batman hoping that Batman
will kill him and if Batman doesn't kill
him well he'll just make doomsday and
have and have Superman killed anyway add
to that the layers that Batman has a
bajillion um gadgets to fight Superman
But ultimately his Ace in the Hole is
the Kryptonite sphere which before the
fight even starts he slams into the
ground and then he goes to phase off
against against Superman why did he set
that up so far away from where the fight
starts how did he know he would end up
there and no the answer for neither
Batman nor Lex Luther of they're just so
smart that they figured it out and could
plan for everything that does not work
in either case because there are so many
needless layers of complexity that do
not need to be there and make it more
vulnerable and make it so it should have
fallen
apart cases like that is where a
villain's plan not working matter
especially if the intention of that
villain is to communicate how smart they
are
really cuz the other thing is none of
this should be necessary to motivate
Batman to want to kill Superman anyway
because they gave a perfectly good
reason for Batman to do that during the
intro of the movie I okay I got to get
off this thing
okay this is your a reminder that I did
actually like the SN cut of Justice
League I just don't like
BBS all right all right of course the SN
Bros are going to get mad at me they
they they would have stopped watching
and wouldn't have heard me say that part
whatever but I kind of had to get it off
my chest because I'm not going to say
it's something that I see super often
but when I see it and it's presented in
this sort of oh I've outwitted the not
only the filmmakers but the the villains
of the movie because I'm smarter than
the villain it doesn't matter if you're
smarter not all villains are smart they
just have to be
dangerous and like I said this isn't
something I see often but when I see it
it rubs me the wrong way so
much I've kind of had this in me for a
little while so there you go hope you
had fun during this venting
session uh I enjoyed it well enough uh
whatever your thoughts are on this drop
something down in the comments let's
talk about it any other examples you
want to give of villains whose plans
should have fallen apart uh at a million
points or one whose plans ultimately
wouldn't have worked but it doesn't
matter for thep purposes of the story
being told whatever you want to share I
want to hear it or your thoughts on what
I've said in general patreon pays the
bills enables me to do this as my living
like share subscribe also help me out if
you don't feel like spending any money
but don't worry too much about it what I
really want you to remember is you are
beautiful you are valid and you are
loved you are the council and I am just
running the meetings and until next time
this council is
adjourned
time to thank some patreon backers and
in the spirit of October I'd like to
thank Robin Moore Zubin L fulla goddess
alter Tac the thing that goes dink in
the anime Ruth Oliver B solitary
pictures or bton Melinda Walters Jen
Auntie Kate 808 Becky Sparks FX The
brutal Robin Powell Tracy scr rabbit
angry caspel Dave Hall and rosn
Bennett thank you for your assistance um
I don't know I might try theming the
shout outs in the future I don't know
we'll see thank
[Music]
you
no